global economic expert hanging FERPA
from hamburg's Institute of
International Economics joins us now mr.
focal thank you very much first of all
for coming on the show and tell me
everyone knows anyone who knows anything
about economics knows that growth can't
go on forever all good things come to an
end but how predictable was this slowing
of growth in those big economies of
Russia China and Brazil I think it was
predictable but nevertheless unexpected
by the markets so we have observed slow
down and growth rates and all of these
countries emerging economies and now the
ones fears or doubts are triggered this
could easily enhanced to a crisis and
spread around the world why contagion
and at the end and finally affect
negatively the global economy how much
of a surprise has the slowdown being
over you it for me it's not a surprise
because this well known and economic
theory that as you said economic growth
of the sixth and which would come to an
end eventually and this exactly has has
happened right now let's focus on China
it's being one of the bigger performers
all the biggest performers and the
global economy is so dependent on that
Chinese growth the slow down there why
first of all well there was an over
optimism in the markets that have has
led to to to this crisis to me it's just
a correction of expectations of over
optimism but we cannot exclude that it
was also enhanced to to crisis and then
negatively affect the global economy so
global investors trusted the Chinese
government's forecasts exactly exactly
but but now we can see that growth is
not that easy after a prolonged period
of high rates of growth now it comes to
an end and we need to find new sources
of growth and China and this is a very
difficult process in China what about
Russia there the political situation is
also very telling yes suffering still
from
sanctions imposed on Russia on the
Russian economy but besides this it's
also the downturn in energy prices so
the Russian economy has relied very
heavily on exports of energy and now
there's slowdown in or downturn in
prices and this has affected the Russian
economy negative ad also trust amongst
its own people the capital flight has
been extremely telling what about Brazil
just lastly its first and foremost a
political crisis rather than economic
crisis so the Brazilian economy needs to
strengthen political institutions
governance in order to to retain trust
in the Brazilian economy okay so in all
three cases a political crisis counted
or working also trying to solve a
financial crisis but in all three cases
a very tricky challenge for those
governments in those countries and the
people exactly all these economies are
only running into what we call a middle
income trap so growth comes to an end
and we need to find new sources of
growth by strengthening institutions
fostering economic growth by by
technical progress and this is a very
tough process get back to you in a
moment